what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have to
talk about some pretty crazy rumors
involving doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness we're talking
today x-men the fantastic four and the
possible return of tony stark but not
like you think there's been a lot of
mystery and rumors surrounding doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
but i personally think this one right
here is the most exciting one out of all
of the things that could happen in
multiverse of madness and there are a
lot of things that happen pretty much
anything is on the table for this movie
but out of anything that could happen i
think this is something that the fans
would love to see so we're gonna talk
fantastic four x-men and the possible
return of tony stark in this video but
if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
news so first things first let's start
off with the x-men because these rumors
have been going around for a while but
there's actually a lot of evidence
suggesting that at least one of them is
going to appear in multiverse of madness
and that one x-men that is seemingly
going to be appearing in multiverse of
madness is professor xavier now i talked
about this i think a couple of weeks ago
in a video talking about multiverse of
madness and professor xavier being in
the movie but recently there's been a
little bit more of development on this
story originally we didn't know which
actor that played professor xavier would
be reprising the role as professor x in
the film the previous report that came
out simply said professor x will show up
however recently there's been a photo
circulating around the internet showing
patrick stewart's professor xavier in
what appears to be his classic iconic
chair now if you have seen this photo i
just want to point out that this is not
confirmed to be real yet a lot of people
are trolling right now however there are
some visual effects people that have
been saying that this does kind of look
like it is in a pre-production edit
because that's what the photo is it
isn't of patrick stewart himself it's of
a cgi mock-up of him now even if this
photo is fake the reports of patrick
stewart reprising his role as professor
x and multiverse of madness are most
likely true and here's why patrick
stewart actually came out about a year
ago and said that he met with marvel
studios president kevin feige and get
this he literally said that he talked to
president kevin feige about reprising
his role as professor xavier he
literally said feige called him in to
talk about appearing as professor x in
the actual mcu now everything in the mcu
is actually kind of canon now and i'll
explain that in a bit but originally
patrick stewart said that he turned down
kevin feige because he put his character
to rest in logan if you haven't seen
logan yet i highly recommend it it's one
of the best marvel movies ever but
spoiler alert for it in the next 15
seconds or so so skip ahead if you don't
want to hear it he dies professor xavier
dies and so does logan but both patrick
stewart and hugh jackman said that that
was the end for their characters that's
when they put them to rest in logan
their character said goodbye and in
return so did they however and i've
stated this many times before so i won't
spend too much time on it since the mcu
has a multiverse now they can return and
reprise their roles without undoing
their past they could simply say it's
just a different variant of the
characters and these variants never died
so the reason that patrick stewart
didn't want to return as professor
xavier has been resolved so we can't
really use that as an excuse to debunk
this report now you have to ask yourself
though why is professor x returning and
this is where things get really really
exciting this report has come from many
different people over the past year
geekgossitymac.com the illuminati and
more but they were the first to report
it report that the illuminati is coming
in multiverse of madness now the
illuminati is something that everybody
should be looking forward to because
they are freaking awesome we're talking
about the head lead superheroes of the
world coming together to form a super
console and essentially decide what each
group the x-men the avengers the
inhumans the fantastic four decide what
each of them are going to do about
threats it's a superhero console and
check out the original lineup iron man
mr fantastic of the fantastic four
professor xavier doctor strange of
course black bolt and namor the
submariner who is rumored to be
appearing in wakanda forever in fact
recently there have been casting calls
for wakanda forever that do point to
namor really being in the film that's a
video for another day though now the
illuminati is rumored to be appearing in
the multiverse of madness it's been
reported by a lot of people like i said
but here's the problem we don't have the
inhumans in the mcu we no longer have an
iron man in the mcu and the fantastic
four have yet to arrive and in a normal
universe this might actually be a
problem but since we're in the
multiverse it's not and that is probably
the coolest thing of multiverse of
madness again anything is possible and
right now it actually sounds like the
illuminati might be kind of similar to
the original comic lineup and right now
the rumor and i do stress rumor i think
it's pretty much confirmed that the
illuminati will be in the film but the
rumor about who all of the characters
will be is a rumor but right now rumor
has it there will be a mr fantastic and
there will be an iron man and this is
where things get really cool the rumored
mr fantastic is rumored to be johann
griffin the same one who played mr
fantastic in the 2005
fantastic four movie it's also rumored
that jessica alba's the invisible woman
could come back with him as well and the
rumor tony stark slash iron man for the
illuminati is going to be tom cruise now
i think this is a combination of two
really good ideas you're taking a
previous marvel movie that doesn't exist
in the main universe but does exist in
the multiverse and bringing him into the
main mcu probably only briefly but in it
nonetheless and then you're taking iron
man and making him tom cruise and for
those of you who aren't aware tom cruise
almost actually played iron man over
robert downey jr so this is kind of a
what if scenario universe what if tom
cruise was actually iron man and not
robert downey jr and if this does
actually happen i think this is actually
incredibly clever on marvel's behalf but
i wouldn't put it past kevin feige at
all and you have to realize this is a
movie about the multiverse specifically
about the multiverse kind of exploding
what better way to show all of that than
to have people from other universes and
people from what if universes appearing
in the actual mcu and what better way to
show the true chaos of it but it looks
like this illuminati is going to be a
multiversal illuminati and if you
actually think about it the rumored cast
actually makes a lot of sense professor
xavier with all of his psychic abilities
and powers would probably be in tune
with the multiverse then you have reed
richards of the fantastic four and iron
man tony stark two of the most brilliant
minds in the marvel universe they both
probably either separately or together
figured out the multiverse as well and
how to access it then at some point in
time they all came together and formed
the illuminati it could be professor x
that brought him together due to his
psychic abilities or perhaps doctor
strange assembled an illuminati
off-screen and we haven't seen it yet
but we will in multiverse of madness
however they are going to be formed it
does look like they are going to be
making their mcu debut in doctor strange
2. and even if only part of these rumors
are true it's going to be absolutely
insane the people who have been working
on it so far have called it bonkers and
apparently this movie is going to be
avengers infinity war and in-game level
we obviously have to get past the
promotion of spider-man no way home
which is the setup for doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness but once we do
that once spider-man no way home comes
out we'll start to get the promotions
for multiverse of madness and since
spider-man is going to already introduce
the multiverse i'm gonna guess that we
do get some teasers for the multiverse
in the trailer and get a little bit of a
glimpse of just how crazy this movie is
going to be but in the meantime let me
know what you think about all of these
crazy reports and rumors in the comments
down below do you want tom cruise to
show up as iron man do you want joanne
gruffed and jessica alba to appear as
the fantastic four members mr fantastic
and the invisible woman and of course do
you want to see professor xavier be
played by patrick stewart and who do you
want to see be a part of the illuminati
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof